the threat of an asteroid hitting earth
is very real if it's big enough
it's also very final
[Music]
these are very very infrequent events
the probability is not zero though
a blinding flash of light streaking
across the sky
about 100 tons of space rock falls on
earth every day
most of it is so small it burns up in
our atmosphere
or lands unnoticed away from major
populations
no human in the past thousand years is
known to have been killed by a meteorite
and according to nasa no large object is
likely to strike the earth
any time in the next several hundred
years
however one thing is certain
we haven't found them all there are
thousands out there
and we don't know where they are
[Music]
there are a lot of asteroids in our
solar system they
number in the billions scientists all
over the world are working toward
detecting
and deflecting the most catastrophic of
natural disasters
the race is on to find as many of these
objects as we can we have a way of
calculating whether or not an asteroid
is potentially dangerous or not i mean i
think it's something worth investing in
it's our existence at stake right
[Music]
amy let's get this one out of the way
it's probably the question you get asked
the most
but how scared should we be asteroids
and comets are
a natural hazard that's out there like a
lot of other natural hazards
uh these are very very infrequent events
these collision events where an object
actually impacts the earth the most
important thing that we need to know
about asteroids is
when the next impact is going to happen
and how bad it will be
what we know is that an object that's
about say a kilometer across
is capable of causing very very wide
devastation across the planet really
truly global devastation
the object that wiped out the dinosaurs
was somewhere in the neighborhood of
five to ten kilometers across so
even bigger than that at a kilometer
it's still going to be very
bad and it will have global effects for
objects that are capable of causing what
i would call
sort of regional damage kind of a large
major metropolitan area
a city and its surrounding environments
sort of around 100 ish meters
it depends on the details of the
composition and so forth
by the 1980s nasa was cataloguing
near-earth objects
in 1994 stargazers watched as comet
shoemaker levy 9
hit jupiter the resulting zone of chaos
was estimated to be as large as the
earth and the event became a turning
point in the search for asteroids and
comets in our solar system
in 1998 congress tasked nasa with
finding ninety percent of asteroids and
comets one kilometer wide or larger
soon after hollywood blockbusters
armageddon and deep
impact brought attention and fear to the
masses
the great news is that the vast majority
more than 90 percent of all the really
large one kilometer
near-earth objects have been found the
challenge now is working down to these
smaller sizes that are still quite
capable of causing a lot of damage
but they're just harder to spot because
they're fainter they're smaller
can you give us a sense of how many are
out there in our solar system
we know that there are a lot of
asteroids in our solar system they
number in the billions most of them
however are between
mars and jupiter in what we call the
main asteroid belt
this is a region of space where most of
the asteroids in the inner part of our
solar system live
and they stay there for many billions of
years there is another population though
that kind of
leaks inward and gets into the region
somewhat close to the earth
and we call these near-earth objects
we think that there are millions and
millions of new earth objects that are
out there in the total population as of
today we know of
sort of around 20 25 000 something like
that when we first spot an object we
really know very little about it we just
see something moving across the sky so
all you get is just sort of a handful of
snapshots
just enough to be able to tell that this
isn't an asteroid that we've already
seen before
and then once we can calculate the
distance to it we can now start to make
predictions about its true size
is it large or is it small so we have a
lot of information that we have to get
pretty quickly
to really understand what's going on
finding asteroids is just one piece of
the puzzle
planetary scientists are extremely
skilled in determining the orbits and
speeds of asteroids based on relatively
small amounts of data
nasa runs simulations of the
trajectories asteroids could take
which is useful but time consuming
a team of scientists in the netherlands
have found a way that could buy us more
time
our method is fairly quick so you can
very quickly get an assessment of
whether or not the object is dangerous
or not
if you look at the classical way of
determining the danger of an asteroid
it may take you know days of computing
time on very big machines
to uh to determine this this
hazardousness
the current problem is that there's just
too many asteroids out there
to spend a huge amount of computational
power on all of them
so the neural network allows us to focus
on
what really could go and uh pose the
hazards of earth
a neural network is a computing system
that mimics the way the human brain
operates
to find underlying relationships in a
set of data by training the network in
this way you
you train it in recognizing those
objects
that are most likely to hit the planet
and once it's trained you can apply this
network to all the unknown asteroids
and then you can make a selection and
say hey this is these are the ones which
appear to be having orbits similar to
the ones which we
know are hitting the planet that doesn't
mean that they do
but it does it only means that they look
very similar to the ones
we we know they do what else did you
find should we be particularly concerned
about anything
one thing that we did find is that our
neural network
was able to go and um identify a handful
of asteroids
which weren't considered potentially
hazardous that
when we went and integrated them forward
in time they came
quite close to earth we find a handful
which were not detected before or not
considered being dangerous before and we
think
they are potentially dangerous it's very
hard to simulate
kind of going forward in time an
asteroid that's going to hit earth
because
well the earth is really small and uh
well space is really big
and then you have to have very exact
parameters to shoot an asteroid that
goes and hits exactly earth
and then simon had the ingenious idea of
not even trying to do that
and just launching the asteroids from
earth's surface
and integrating backwards in time it's
very hard to make it hit
so you need a lot of a lot of
calculations which all end up in nothing
and the idea was then like well let's
not do that this is basically what nasa
is doing nasa is taking an asteroid
making multiple copies of them
shooting them all forwards in time
calculating their orbits
and then see what fraction sort of gets
close to earth not even hitting earth
but getting close to earth
and that they call it a potential
impactor so you calculate the solar
system forwards in time for let's say
a thousand years and then you launch
asteroids from the surface as if they if
you go forwards in time would fall on
the surface
you calculate them backwards to today
and then you get your orbital parameters
of today's asteroids which you know will
land on the planet
and those you can use as known impactors
and compare with all the other asteroids
in the in the solar system
can simulations and ai can those things
fill in the gaps where perhaps
telescopes and
other imaging tools can't absolutely
since the observations get more complex
the physics gets more complex and if the
physics get more complex the mathematics
becomes more complex
and at some point you can't solve your
problems analytically anymore
and then it's where the computer comes
in now we have this trained neural
network we have a way of calculating in
a fraction of a second
whether or not an asteroid is
potentially dangerous or not and
therefore deserves more attention
or or more time to spend on for
for really finding out if it is
dangerous
when it comes to hunting asteroids time
is critical
what we can do about a potentially
hazardous object depends a great deal on
what we know about it and
how much time we have before the
encounter we'd really like to find them
when they're decades away
because the more time you have the more
options you have
and the less energy it takes to to move
an object aside
it also means we might not have to
resort to launching a nuclear warhead as
an asteroid
until recently pretty much our only
choice that's an option of last resort
in my opinion yes
we have lots of options available you
can just simply
bump into the object and just nudge it
out of the way
that's one possibility and that's kind
of in a way sort of the simplest thing
to think about just
nudging it off its path a little bit
with you know a massive object
a spacecraft let's say it's kind of like
bowling if you will
you know if you have a long time or a
long stretch of
runway in the lane just a very small
twist on the on the bowling ball will
make a big change in where it ultimately
ends up
another option it would be something
where you take a very big
big massive spacecraft and you park it
next to the object and you use
the force of gravity as a towing
rig that takes longer though and you
need to be able to send a pretty massive
spacecraft and obviously depends a lot
on
how big the asteroid is other options
start to get more and more
complicated and they range from
painting one side of the object a white
color and painting the other side dark
and then letting
the pressure of light sort of perturb
its orbit
in a departure from the lab and computer
simulations
nasa has real plans to rehearse kinetic
impact deflection
in 2021 the agency will launch dart the
double asteroid redirection test mission
which will intercept a 160 meter
asteroid in 2022
better to practice now before we have to
deal with an actual threat
in the meantime discovering asteroids is
our best bet
thousands of scientists and amateur
astronomers around the world
make up an informal network that survey
the heavens
but that may not be enough nasa wants
more resources to map our solar system
and better technology we need to
ramp up our network of sensors and also
uh we need to just continue to
strengthen our network of international
observers so that we can get follow-up
because we find these objects when
they're distributed all over the night
sky
once we get more observations we get
better data we can make better
predictions
if you look at the big impactors we have
had in the last
let's say 20 years or maybe 30 years 50
years
most of them we haven't seen coming so
the danger the real danger i think comes
from the objects we don't know about
and not from the object we do know about
this particular natural disaster like a
lot of natural disasters and like
climate change is a problem of the
global commons
so the thing that we risk collectively
is that it sort of then becomes
nobody's problem and nobody takes
ownership over it asteroids
are all over the sky they just truly
cross boundaries and borders
with a second's notice i kind of imagine
in the future
maybe lots of small satellites around
the earth that are always going and
looking outward
i mean i think it's something worth
investing in it's our existence at stake
[Music]
right